- - Martine Biron, Michel C Augr
etet Nathalie Grammont, bonsoir.
- - Madame Anglade a un test de
leleadership. Marie mon petit
exexclu du caucus. Stéphanie,
vovotre journal nous apprend qul
y y a eu des plaintes pour
haharcèlement psychologique.
MaMartine, qu'est-ce qu'on en st
cece soir? Ça s'est fait par
ététapes. En fin de semaine,
MaMadame mon petit M. Barr et ot
peperdu leur responsabilité et
vovoici qu'on l'exclut. Qu'est-e
ququi est arrivé?
- - J'ai écrit vendredi sur la
sisituation aux parties et les
rarapports difficiles de Madame
momon petit avec beaucoup
d'd'employés politiques. Madame
MoMontpetit a contredit Monsieur
BaBarrette sur Twitter. Dominiqe
AnAnglade en apprend tous les
jojours un peu plus sur Marie mn
pepetit. Je crois que ce n'est s
lala fin des allégations. Ce
n'n'était plus possible de la
gagarder au sein de son caucus.
ElElle n'a pas dit qu'il
sosouhaitait revoir Gaétan
BaBarrette candidat à la prochae
élélection. Le PLQ a mis une crx
susur la réforme Barrette.
- - Je veux vous entendre sur
MoMonsieur Barrette après. Lui,l
n'n'y a pas de plainte ni
d'd'allégation. C'est une autre
hihistoire. C'est qu'il ne
rerespecte pas le territoire de
MaMadame Montpetit comme critiqe
dede la santé. Sur Marie mon
pepetit, est-ce que ce qu'on
alallègue était reconnu? Il faut
ququ'il y ait une enquête.
- - Savait très longtemps qu'ily
a a des rumeurs qui courent au
susujet de son comportement à
l'l'égard de ses collègues
dédéputés, de ses employés
popolitiques et même cela quand
elelle était avec Philippe
CoCouillard. C'est connu. Vendri
mamatin, j'ai publié et je
rerecevais beaucoup de témoignas
dede députés, de personnel
popolitique. Ça se confirme de
plplus en plus. On s'attend peu-
êêtre à ce qu'il y a autre chose
ququi sorte cette semaine.
- - Ce n'est jamais bon d'avoirn
efeffeuillage de problème dans n
paparti politique. Deuxièmement,
onon est dans une époque où on e
totolère plus cela. On ne tolère
plplus de harcèlement
pspsychologique. S'il y avait
plplusieurs plaintes, exclure
MaMadame Monpetit du caucus état
lala chose à faire. Ça arrive ds
unun contexte avec ce qui est
ararrivé vendredi, l'engueulade
papar tweets interposés avec
GaGaétan Barrette, ça nuit à
DoDominique Anglade.
- - Stéphanie, sur les
alallégations, il faudra quand
mmême qu'il y a un processus où
elelle puisse se faire entendre.
IlIl y a quand même la justice?
- - Effectivement, il faut tirer
leles choses au clair. On ne pet
papas non plus... je défends le
trtravail de Tommy Chouinard das
lala presse ce matin qui a
ssûrement fait toutes les
vévérifications nécessaires avat
dede publier son article, où ily
avavait des allégations sérieus.
JeJe suis d'accord avec vous
ququ'elle a quand même droit dee
dédéfendre. Elle a dit qu'elle e
feferait. Pour la chef, Dominiqe
AnAnglade, comme disait Michel,n
nene veut pas étirer la douleur.
OnOn ne veut pas attendre d'agir
etet de se faire accuser d'avoir
agagi trop tard. Je pense à Jule
PaPayette, qui s'est accroché à
soson poste de gouverneur générl
pependant très longtemps et c'et
dedevenu extrêmement douloureux.
CeCe sont des choses qu'on accee
plplus aujourd'hui,
l'l'intimidation, harcèlement
pspsychologique. Il n'y a plus e
totolérance pour cela.
EfEffectivement, il fallait
prprendre les devants.
- - Pour Dominique Anglade,
prprenant l'exemple de Gaétan
BaBarrette. Je comprends qu'elle
sosouhaite qu'il ne se représene
papas, mais elle fait quoi d'ici
llà?
- - Est-ce qu'elle va passer au
trtravers? À ce moment-ci, à 17
heheures 38, je ne peux pas
rérépondre à cette question. C't
unun caucus très compliqué, ilsy
enen a qui sont proches de la
sosortie, ils y en a qui veulent
bbâtir. C'est un parti qui n'a
papas vraiment de mission. Il ya
2,2,3 et quatre clans. Il n'y a
papas de ciment dans ce parti. n
nene sait pas c'est quoi, Parti
lilibéral. Il n'y a pas de
cocohésion idéologique. Ça parat
auau caucus, qui est assez
dédésagrégé. Il y a des têtes ps
fofortes que d'autres. Comment
esest-ce que Dominique Anglade a
raramener son caucus ensemble?
EsEst-ce qu'elle va être capable
d'd'avoir la confiance de tous?i
elelle perd la moitié du caucus,
elelle est dans une situation ts
emembêtante pour la suite des
chchoses. Il y en a en coulisse
ququi commence à penser à un pln
B.B.
- - Pour les citoyens, ce qui
reregarde ça, il n'y a pas
bebeaucoup de façons de savoir i
lala chef de l'opposition à
ququelqu'un qui va faire une boe
prpremière ministre. La seule
fafaçon qu'ils ont, c'est de
reregarder comment elle dirige n
paparti et son aile parlementai.
S'S'il y a du trouble à
paparlementaires, le caucus
lilibéral n'est pas si gros que
çaça, ils sont 27. À la fin, les
cicitoyens ordinaires se disent
quque cette personne-là ne peut
papas être première ministre si
elelle n'est pas capable de garr
lele parti d'opposition. Ça a ft
lala peau de plusieurs chefs
d'd'opposition, cette difficult-
llà.
- - Même si elle était une
mamagicienne, devant un
gogouvernement si populaire chez
leles francophones au Québec, sa
mamarge de manoeuvre est étroit.
- - C'est clair qu'elle n'a pasa
roroute facile. On est à un an s
prprochainines élections
prprovinciales. Il y a des dépus
ququi se battre entre autres au
lilieu de unir leurs forces et e
trtrouver une façon de faire une
lulutte sérieuse à la CAQ. On et
mamal parti. Il va falloir qu'il
sese passe quelque chose
rarapidement, par ce que la CAQa
dédéjà commencé à fourbir ses
ararmées à se lancer un peu en
cacampagne officieuse. C'est pas
cocomme ça qui vont arriver à
fafaire contrepoids.
- - Michel, vous avez écrit un
tetexte en fin de semaine sur le
dédéluge de publicité, quand vos
ddîtes campagne de la CAQ,
j'j'aimerais vous entendre là-
dedessus. On ouvrait les machin.
LaLa publicité gouvernementale à
BeBeaujeu.
- - Sur la COVID, on a dépensé
plplus d'argent... il y avait ds
pupublicités qui étaient un peu
sosociétales. On voit des
coconférences de presse du
gogouvernement avec des vedette,
onon voit des annonces sur la
lalangue avec Jean Béliveau, Jen
LeLesage. On tout ça et de la
pupublicité sociétale. Qui
lélégifère sur la langue
prprésentement, c'est la CAQ. On
vovoit qu'ils vont mettre des
reressources gouvernementales
énénormes dans l leur réélection
dedernier petit mot sur Dominiqe
AnAnglade, et la la malédiction
dedes chefs élus par acclamatio.
UnUn moment donné, il y a une
papartie du parti qui leur dit
ququ'ils n'ont pas voté pour el.
- - Un petit mot sur l'instrumet
ThThiem M. Legault, la publicité
gogouvernementale. On l'a vu los
dudu discours d'ouverture
ininaugurale. Il avait fait toue
unune vidéo. On ne s'en privera
papas.
- - C'est intéressant, ce dossi,
paparce qu'on est dans un contee
d'd'élections à date fixe. L'ane
élélectorale, la question se po.
ToTout le monde dépense davantae
etet le parti au pouvoir à
l'l'avantage, parce qu'il peut
prprofiter de ses actions
gogouvernementales pour faire de
lala propagande partisane. Ça va
poposer la question du plafond e
dédépenses en année électorale à
papartir du 1er janvier 2022. Le
DGDGEQ avait documenté à la
dedernière élection comment chae
paparti politique avait dépensén
pépériode préélectorale. Si je e
sosouviens bien, c'est à peu prs
14144 % de plus dans l'année
prpréélectorale en 2018 avant,
ququ'on n'était pas en électionà
dadate fixe. Ce convoi présent
avavec les chiffres que Michèlea
didivulgués en fin de semaine, a
vava revenir, le débat va sûremt
sese faire sur cette question.
- Entre-temps, Monsieur Legault
s's'en va à Glasgow à la COP.
StStéphanie, vous avez écrit sur
lele troisième lien en disant :
ououbliez donc ça. Quels sont ls
enenjeux pour Monsieur Trudeau?
- - L'enjeu est énorme, parce
ququ'on doit se fixer des cibles
etet il faut pas juste les fixe,
mamais aussi les atteindre. Au
QuQuébec, les cibles fixées en e
momoment, on a seulement 40 % du
chchemin de parcouru pour s'y
rerendre. Les actions qu'on a
anannoncées en ce moment vont
pepermettre d'atteindre seulemet
4040 % de cet objectif. Elle ree
énénormément à faire. C'est un u
dadans ce contexte que je disai,
j'j'écrivais que le troisième ln
esest un projet à enterrer.
MoMonsieur Legault lui-même la
sesemaine dernière à concéder qe
cece n'était pas en lien avec ls
obobjectifs verts du gouverneme.
C'C'est un boulet qu'il traîne à
GlGlasgow. On ne va pas comprene
ququel est l'objectif de
coconstruire ce tunnel, qui non
seseulement n'est pas vert maisn
plplus va coûter une fortune ete
rérépond pas à un besoin qui est
vrvraiment évident.
- - J'entends les gens de Québec
didirent : on le sait, une
édéditorialiste de Montréal. Vos
nene connaissez pas la circulatn
àà Québec!
- - Toutes les personnes à qui
j'j'ai parlé sont des gens de
QuQuébec et de Lévis et il y a
plplein de gens là-bas qui ne st
papas en faveur du projet. Je
pepense qu'on va tous payer 10
mimilliards de dollars ou peut-
êêtre plus à la fin et comme
cocontribuables, on a quand même
lele droit de se poser des
ququestions sur un projet qui
cocoûte très cher et qui va être
popolluant.
- - Je pense que Monsieur Legaut
lului-mmême commença sans poser
plplus.
- - Ce n'était pas dans son
didiscours d'ouverture d'une hee
etet quart. C'est un projet de 0
mimilliards de dollars,
gégénéralement, quand tu es prêà
dédépenser 10 milliards pour un
prprojet, tu t'en vantes et tu
fafais une petite publicité. S'l
n'n'en parle pas, il y a des
raraisons à ça. Chaque semaine,n
esessaie de verdir davantage le
prprojet. On va voir ce qu'il va
fafaire avec ce projet mais pour
l'l'instant, c'est mal barré.
- - Monsieur Trudeau amène
StStéphane Guilbault, le ministe
dadans l'environnement à la COP
2626. Est-ce que Monsieur Trudeu
ararrive avec des cartes à joue?
EnEn essayant de faire oublier e
lele Canada est quand même le sl
papays du G7 qui a augmenté ses
émémissions?
- - La carte que joue Monsieur
TrTrudeau en amenant Monsieur
GuGuilbault, c'est qu'au Canada,
onon reconnaît qu'on a été des
bebeaux parleurs et des petits
fafaiseurs on va essayer de
chchanger ça. C'est une chose
imimportante dans le contexte. l
fafaut reconnaître effectivement
quque le Canada a joué beaucoup
susur du vieux gagné. S'il n'y
avavait pas l'électricité au
QuQuébec, on a un sérieux
prproblème. Monsieur Legault dit
ququ'on est les premiers sur 60
ététats en Amérique du Nord, ou,
mamais à cause de
l'l'hydroélectricité. Par contr,
onon a le même problème, les
grgrandes distances et l'hiver,
ququi ne s'en ira pas de sitôt.n
vava toucher quand même à la vie
dedes citoyens. Il faut parler s
vovoitures et de ces choses-là t
cece n'est pas encore commencé,i
auau Québec ni a au Canada.
- - Vous touchez quelque chose
d'd'essentiel, les élus devront
didire aux gens : il y aura un
cocoût à payer. Deux voitures, s
ququartiers excentrés, pas près
dedes gares, on ne peut pas.
- - C'est ce qu'il va falloir
ququ'il y a un impact dans nos
vivies un certain moment, parce
ququ'autrement, on n'y arrivera
papas. C'est pour ça que des
prprojets comme le troisièmeme n
ququi mise sur la voiture, sur
l'l'étalement urbain, où on dit:
onon a de la congestion alors on
bbâtit encore plus. C'est un peu
cocomme décider de régler le
prproblème d'obésité en déboutoa
sasa chemise. Ça ne marche pas.l
fafaut se mettre au régime.
- - Vous avez fait le caméraman,
c'c'est toujours bon signe.
MaMartine, il va y avoir une
anannonce de M. Legault concernt
AlAlsthom et le siège social à
QuQuébec et peut-être des contrs
bibientôt.
- - Le transport électrique,
AlAlsthom, c'est ça qu'on veut
fafavoriser. C'est ça qu'on veut
enenvoyer comme message à la COP
2626. C'est-à-dire que
l'l'électrification des
trtransports, c'est important et
lele Québec va jouer un rôle das
cece sens-là. La batterie de
l'l'Amérique du Nord, on entenda
dedepuis le début du mandat. Il
cocontinue sur cette ligne.
- - Le grand patron d'Air Canada
vivient donner un discours devat
lala chambre de commerce de
MoMontréal. Jusque-là, tout va
bibien. Or, on apprend qu'il sea
ununiquement, Monsieur Rousseau,
mamalgré son nom francophone, il
nene parle pas français du tout,
mamais il peut lire un texte.
StStéphanie, comment avez-vous
réréagi? On a confirmé, la port-
paparole d'Air Canada l'a confié
auaujourd'hui, il va venir à
MoMontréal, le siège social d'Ar
CaCanada et Montréal, en théori,
ilil va venir parler au Québec
sasans parler français!
- - Malheureusement, j'étais pas
susurprise. C'est pas que je
l'l'approuve, comprenez-moi bie,
mamais Air Canada dans le passée
nonous a jamais prouvé qu'il étt
unun bon citoyen corporatif en
tetermes de langue française ete
bibilinguisme. C'est quelque che
ququi suit l'entreprise depuis
lolongtemps. Malheureusement, ça
nene fait que nous donner la
prpreuve que les passagers, tout
lele monde avait raison de se
plplaindre parce que le servicen
frfrançais à bord des avions à
totoutes souvent été critiquées.
C'C'est comme si le président
pepersonne concrétise un peu,
crcristallise cette impression.e
pepense que c'est malheureux. Ça
ararrive à un point où justemen,
onon va essayer de renforcer la
lalangue française dans les
ininstitutions comme Air Canada,
dedes institutions fédérales. Ça
enenvoie le signal contraire.
- - C'est la chambre de commerce
dede Montréal qui doit réagir.
C'C'est elle qui doit dire que a
n'n'a pas d'allure qu'à notre
trtribune, dans le siège social
d'd'Air Canada, est-ce que la
chchambre de commerce de
VaVancouver, quelqu'un pourrait
fafaire un discours uniquement
frfrançais? Bien sûr que non.
C'C'est aussi à la chambre de
cocommerce de dire que ça va un
pepeu trop loin.
- - C'est étonnant, parce qu'on
pepeut penser qu'une entreprise
cocomme Air Canada à des
didirecteurs de communication bn
papayée pour conseiller ses
didirigeants et leur dire que la
prprotection de la langue, ça ft
dédébat au Québec et au Canada.
C'C'est sur à peu près toutes ls
lalangues. Effectivement, il
dedevrait au moins... si Marie
SiSimon a été capable de
babaragouiner quelques phrases n
frfrançais...
MaMartine, Michel et Stéphanie,
totoujours un plaisir. À la
prprochain